do you believe
in ghosts you know what i mean because
i saw a ghost man i think i saw the
ghost
yeah i know what you mean but
do you know what i mean yes i know what
you mean by
ghosts people don't say hey go you know
hey i was at the racetrack i saw those
ghosts going in a circle i know what you
mean
you know we went fishing my buddy reeled
in a seven pound ghost i know what you
mean guy okay
thank you for the call also
and do i believe in ghosts
well
yes
because i you know
i've forgot something in another room
before you know where you got to go get
something you leave something at home
or you have to call a diner in maine and
tell them to mail your air pod
i believe stuff all the time
so i can imagine a soul just kind of
leaves something but then you got to
come back and get it
you know
uh
and i think it's easy for a soul to get
out of a body's pretty
you know a body is it's just a dirty
bird cage baby this thing is
it's not that strong really it's great
because it makes our all our organs just
be like a team but
it's not that go stab yourself
stab yourself four times man
don't call anybody for eight minutes see
how you do
you know what i'm saying
bodies only can only handle so much
and i don't i don't blame ghosts for
leaving somebodies
i don't blame ghosts for
some bodies if i'm a ghost i'm a spirit
i'm out
some guy doesn't brush his teeth for a
month dude i'm ghosted i'm out okay
some guy's in a domestic dispute dude
and him he's in a standoff with the
police
i'm out
i think you're gonna see a lot more
ghosts because i think ghosts are tired
of being we're just you know people
screwing around
just drinking damn mountain dews all day
if i'm a ghost and i want to do more
running if i'm that david goskins i'm
out
that that's probably who a lot of
spirits are a lot of spirits are just
a lot of ghosts are just uh spirits that
left home because [ __ ] was getting bad
in the body
you know you you realize you know
your owner or whatever can't read
and he's 30. um
i'm leaving
goes by
i'm not staying around inside of
somebody at a certain point that's not
toeing there into the line
you know you you dude's out there
playing dice and he's 41.
i'm out
[Music]
so i'm not shocked that a lot of ghosts
are really
i think you'll see more ghosts
because i think a lot of these spirits
are getting tired of they thought we
were going to do something with this
whole deal and we're just [ __ ] people
are just masturbating and looking you
know doing binoculars and [ __ ]
if that's all and i'm a spirit
sayonara i'm out
ever moved out of a bad neighborhood
that's that's a ghost
that's a ghost these days
the bodies they're in
they're not cutting it
and they just say hey
i'm done here
i'm gonna go look for something else so
yeah
i believe in ghostbub i do believe in
them
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one